let's go to our next caller from the
three-two-three area code caller from
three to three
who's this what's on your mind oh oh
I mean wouldn't happen in the Big Bang
okay hold on a second so you sound like
you're underwater and I didn't catch
your name and I can barely hear you so
let's let's talk through it what's your
name okay very good
tell me once more what your question is
and it please if we're on speaker or
Bluetooth take us off because you sound
like you're underwater no my phone is
not that okay what would happen with the
big banks or not do that if the big
banks were not bailed out is that the
question well some of them would likely
have failed what if the big banks were
not bailed out some of them would likely
have gone under but what would have
happened with the economy I mean that's
that's the argument right that's exactly
the argument which is once you have it
would have been bad for the economy so
once you get this is an argument from
many economists and political analysts
of the economy which is if you have an
entity that is so big that its failure
would destroy the economy then maybe
it's just too big and it shouldn't have
been allowed to get so big in the first
place that's one of the main arguments
do you agree with Obama bailing enough
I'm sorry do I agree with Obama and bado
oh man I got a bail I got a baby I'm
sorry did you hear what that last yes if
you agree with Obama bailing them out
Bailey actually george w bush who did
that Obama supported them yeah III mean
listen I I am against so this is one of
those things like what's with the
example I can understand how if you
start from scratch
certain types of protectionism would
make sense but once you have
200 years of economic history to drop
tariffs in at that point can be damaging
for the economy I would not like the
governor that the government not be in
the business of bailing banks out
I would rather a situation where the
banks never get so big that we are sort
of held over a barrel by them in the
first place given that we were there I
understand what the economic
consequences would have been if not
bailing them out right so it's I mean
you these issues are usually a little
more complex then such a question would
imply